la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
quand l'art et le cochon se retrouve à
saint pierre c'est pour célébrer un
anniversaire en cette année 2014
la super fête en effet ses 40 ans 40
bougies qui marque la naissance de la
coopérative des producteurs de porcs de
la réunion donc on peut démarrer le 11
février 1974 dans une salle de réunion
des environs avec 14 éleveurs durant
quatre décennies la petite coopérative
des premiers débuts vinci grandir et se
développer dans son berceau saint
pierrois tout notre développement s'est
fait sur cette commune avec le soutien
ford qui se sont succédé à la mairie
et c'est tout à fait logiquement on se
retrouve ici à saint pierre pour fêter
ses 40 ans la cppm compte aujourd'hui
250 éleveurs adhérents parmi eux patrice
attia mans le jeune homme se souvient
encore de l'époque où son père débuté
comme éleveur dans la jeune coopérative
depuis ma main mais avec les tout débuts
et des balbutiements de la cppa on était
là et ben c'était fait ça c'était super
pour nous c'était une grande joie des
gros camions revenir prendre les cochons
bah ça nous donnait envie de continuer
dans cette voie mais après au fil des
années tout petit on venait les réunions
ont rencontré des personnes et
beth a amplifié chez nous cette envie
cette passion de reprendre le flambeau
c'est en 2007 que patrice reprend
l'exploitation familiale
non sans avoir décroché au préalable de
solide bagage sur revenu j'ai fait une
licence à l'école développement durable
j'ai fait un master en management
d'entreprise et après l'ag je me suis
dit ben maintenant le gène et of bagages
w vraiment m'investir dans mon travail
et pour cette occasion aussi je tiens à
remercier tous mes enseignants tous mes
formateurs qui m'ont poussé à réussir
dans la vie qu'il m'a fait progresser à
prendre des initiatives de
responsabilité
et là dessus je tiens à remercier et un
grand remerciement aussi à jean eddy
lauret il se reconnaîtra on est passé de
5,3 qu'instruit 30 détruit et la
tranquille truies onu la ceinture sur 7
personnellement je délègue pas je fais
tout moi-même donc c'est suffisant pour
moi c'est le travail et c'est ma passion
donc je le fais naturellement
la passion des bons produits c'est aussi
ce qui anime gilbert de res ami maître
charcutier à grand bois
il met un point d'honneur à mettre en
valeur le port pays
c'est ce que les clients recherchent une
très bonne qualité de viande je veux
dire à tout le monde veut bien dans son
assiette manger aujourd'hui manger je
voulais on veut bien manger je veux dire
il faut manger un qualité aussi donc
voila et puis on a un groupement d hier
qui est qui est de rigueur un la
coopérative qui a fêté ses 40 ans qui a
du métier quand même qu'il ya quarante
ans de métier
les éleveurs ce sont des gens très
professionnels résultat n'a rien on a
une qualité de fort qui est
exclusivement supérieur vous appréciez
ici c'est quoi c'est là c'est là qu'est
et la qualité des marchandises comédien
donc ouais et n'a beaucoup de monde il
ya ici un donner envie aux plus grands
nombres de cuisine et du port pays
c'est aussi l'objectif de ce livre
réalisé par lassé ppr 40 années
d'existence de la coopérative traduite
en 40 recettes gourmandes concoctées par
40 chef formateur à l'as far de
saint-andré et disciples d'escoffier il
bouvier et l'un d'entre eux pierre
aujourd'hui d'avoir participé lui aussi
à la réussite de ce projet moi j'avais
choisi les travers de porc parce que
j'estime que ça fait on oublie souvent
que les travers de porc sont quand même
un produit noble et vu la qualité de
cette viande
j'ai pu enfin réaliser quelque chose de
très très très sympathique de très
goûteux était donc travers de porc laqué
orange un jean je n'ai rien inventé à
c'est une recette qui existent en
matière un peu revisitée mais tout en
restera que des produits et pays avec
une mousseline de patates douces en
accompagnement jeune chef créatif et
ardent défenseur du terroir réunionnais
alexandre galmard a choisi quant à lui
le mariage des saveurs exotiques pour
sublimer sa recette de port pays ce que
j'ai essayé de retransmettre dans ma
recette le travers de porc claqué à la
vanille
c'est un petit peu fait à découvrir un
petit peu tous les ingrédients qu'on
peut trouver la réunion entre les
mélanger indien
chinois et metropolit a jugé assaisonner
le travers de porc cas d'accès l'ugc
confiant et pour agrément tous
agrémentés tout ça je les fais avec des
aubergines confites au vinaigre
juste peut rapporter à peine d'acidité
hopelab le but de cette loi c'est que
toutes les recettes soit accessible à
toutes les ménagères enfin toute
personne qui aime cuisiner en fin de
contrat et pas de complication il n'y a
rien d'exceptionnel mais il faut faire
ça les camions
donc
bon